so today we have a new topic for our
webinars and the topic is designing your
life in this section we're going to be
talking about sort of one of the classic
design tools is a reframe and we're
going to be reframing this notion of
passion which is a notion I really don't
like so design thinking for those of you
who are you know in the webinar audience
probably a lot of you have either done
one of our other webinars on this or
you've been reading about it or seeing
something about it you've probably seen
this diagram we have a diagram that's
got you know hexagons and we say that
this is our process we start with
empathy we redefine problems come up
with lots of ideas and prototypes and
tests and it's a it's a methodology of
innovation
you know that's become quite popular in
business and in strategy but the the
question is appropriate today's
discussion is can you apply Design
Thinking to this interesting sort of
wicked problem of designing maybe your
job or your career could you turn your
careers your calling and maybe could you
even design something as big and it's
important but as ambiguous as your life
and we're going to we're going to make
the claimant argue that you can do that
so as I'm thinking is a methodology that
doesn't replace other methods
engineering thinking very powerful way
of solving problems but to think to use
engineering methods you need a pretty
clearly defined problem because you'll
need to isolate knowns and unknowns and
solving for the unknowns requires that
you have enough data to resolve or
complete the equations a business
thinking is another kind of thinking
very powerful where you use figures of
Merit like net present value or the rate
of return on certain investments to make
decisions but design thinking we
typically pull out of our toolkit when
we've got a problem that's really
ambiguous want to design a new
Khai new cellphone and you could study
users all day long and if we were in the
era of the Motorola RAZR our flip phones
none of the user data poles focus groups
and none of that stuff whatever have
created an iPhone iPhone is a sort of
disruptive innovation and that comes
from a design team at Apple that really
really really studied user behaviors
tested ideas rapidly and then evolved
the iPhone if you remember reading
Walter Isaacson's biography not the new
one but the old one of Steve Jobs he
turned down the phone three times
because it wasn't good enough so
whenever humans are engaged in the
problem whenever the problem is
ambiguous or what's called a wicked
problem that's actually a term a couple
guys at Berkeley came up with in the 70s
wicked problem some problems that don't
have a better don't have a yes or no
answer they just have better and worse
once you solve the problem a new problem
emerges this is a classic thing in
design where you you study users you
build exactly what they tell you you
want you show it to them and they say no
I changed my mind
I don't want that anymore so Design
Thinking is the tool we turn to most
often when we have in a big ambiguous
problem that is poorly defined poorly
bounded and that sounded a lot to us
like your life and so you know we we
were originally inspired by the question
the one question that whenever we talk
about this everybody brings up and it's
the one question that never seems to go
away and that's the question of what do
I want to be when I grow up when we were
first proposing using design thinking in
this domain we were talking to lots of
people on campus our Dean of the School
of Engineering Jim Plummer who just
stepped down this year and when we told
him about the class and and Jim is a
highly accomplished professor one of the
best Dean's we've ever had in the School
of Engineering had been the Dean for
almost 10 years and was stepping down to
restart his academic career and he said
I want to take the class because I don't
know what I want
when I grow up and we find that across
the board with people we talked to in
their 20s and 30s and 40s and 50s and
60s that everybody's still in you know
still somewhere along the line they have
to face the question of what do I want
to do next and what does that mean to me
and so it seemed to us and us being my
partner in this endeavor Dave Evans who
is a lecturer here at Stanford he's one
of the founders of Electronic Arts is
one of the first guys at Apple on the
Macintosh team a very innovative person
who's also really interested in concern
about young adult formation and how do
people figure out what they want to do
when they grow up and he and I started
down this path and you know we've
created the thing we call the D life
labs and we've been teaching these
classes instead of evolving this
curriculum since about 2006 we started
with a class called designing your life
which was originally targeted at my
senior students who were about to leave
the university and face what we call the
decision explosion you know these are
highly implemented students they've been
students you know for eighteen or twenty
years of their lives they they worked
hard hard hard you know in elementary
school to make sure they got into a good
high school and then they were heartened
a good high school to get into a school
like Stanford and then they picked a
difficult major like engineering or or
your science and accomplished that but
when they get to the end of their senior
year there are no more hurdles you can
delay the decision explosion with
graduate school but I refuse to read
letters of recommendation for my
students if the only reason they want to
go to graduate school is so they don't
have to think about what what to do next
but they're highly accomplished at
hurdle jumping but they're no more
hurdles at the end of their senior year
and so they face this for the first time
in their lives really this this notion
of having to make decisions and in in
uncharted waters after that class became
quite successful just have an article in
Fast Company about this class and we
were asked to do a classroom for
freshmen which is called designing a
Stanford we now do a class for master
students and PhD students
call designing the professional and
off-campus we run a mid-career workshop
for people in their you know 30s 40s 50s
were working on this problem and I got
to say of all the class this is just a
side project for me I'm addition to you
know this this is mostly just what I was
doing just to help my seniors so I
didn't have to do this in office hours
the you know my main job is to run stat
design programs where we give degrees in
time and most of this is taking these
classes are not design students but I'd
have to say there has also been rather
amazing this is the one class now I get
from the students from 2006 2007 2008 I
get emails all the time from people
saying I'm still using the designing
like tools and techniques I'm designing
you know my my first my first job was
fantastic my second job is going to be
even better this really helps ground me
in the world gives me a voice place to
speak from and you know thank you so
much and by the way since all my
colleagues at work don't know how to do
this I'm teaching them these techniques
so it's kind of gone viral in a way we
weren't expecting but I think it's
because it's an interesting problem
what's the most interesting problem the
most interesting problem is you and what
do you spend most of your time thinking
about you spend most of your time
thinking about what's going to work for
you and it's print and it's an uncharted
you know poorly bounded problem it's
really about designing the future but
you can't know anything about the future
not specifically and so you need these
kinds of iterative and dynamic
techniques to sort of design your way
into the future that you want to have
and have some agency in that so it's
been an exciting journey and we're in
the process of putting the class into a
book that book will be on about a year
but we thought we'd introduce you to
some of the ideas and one of the one of
the ideas that we talked about is this
notion of passion a lot of career
guidance or life guidance starts with
hey what are you passionate about tell
me what you're passionate about and I'll
tell you how to get it
and we for most people that's a pretty
destructive question it turns out and
we're talking about data we get from
Bill Daymond is one of our colleagues
here at Stanford
he runs the Center for the Study of
adolescents and he takes out lessons all
the way up to 25 but there's other
studies that think that that take bills
work past 25 into your 30s or 40s or 50s
and it turns out that if you survey
people the data tells us that only about
20% of the population can identify any
singular passion something that drives
their activities every day something
around which they can form their career
their calling
you know their work in the world and it
turns out basically when you're talking
about you know you know highly educated
and really people with lots of capacity
this question really doesn't work at all
because the rest of us either have many
many things that excite us lots and lots
of different passion or no one thing
that rises to the level of that one
thing I want to do for the rest of my
life so you know we kind of reject a
technique that that starts with 80% of
the people not able to engage because if
you if you've ever run across this
question or you've been working on G
what I want to do with my career what's
what comes next for me I'm kind of bored
in this job and not sure what I want to
do and somebody says well just tell me
what your passion is and then we're
ready to go and you can't identify one
what happens the research tells us is
that you're actually set back even
farther than the starting point of where
you had been originally because now you
go on a pursuit of something that you
don't have and that the research tells
us you you probably are not going to
find passions are not something that
that are intrinsic inside of you and
then you simply realize them the
research says that what happens is you
work and by working in different roles
you discover the rules that have the
best
for you that has fit for Strings
signature strengths and the rolls that
start to turn on a passion for the work
so it's not something you have or find
it's something you work into and so
everybody's got it backwards or at least
everybody who's not in the 20% has it
backwards and it sets people back and
we're really the anti passion guys so
we're not going to start there there is
a there's up there's a big sign over the
Graduate design studio it's right
outside the front door the students have
put up and the sign says you are here we
start with wherever you are we've got a
passion great we can work with that
don't have a passion doesn't matter
we're pretty agnostic about the the
starting point as long as it's it's
really grounded in who you are and what
you know about yourself now because it's
an interesting problem to try to invent
your future the the the the recognition
of your future is a difficult thing to
have since by definition your future
doesn't exist let's try a couple of
really simple little experiments and
I'll explain this might help explain
what I'm talking about so this is a
really simple simple diagram and I'm
going to ask you what you see don't
bother you know you don't have to you
don't have to send in a chat or anything
just just look at this and we'll do this
without with that feedback you're
looking at this bunch of spots of you
know ink on the page what do you see
started for a little while kind of hard
to figure out what it is particularly in
a probably a webinar I'm not sure what
the resolution you guys are seeing is
that but what it is is there's a
Dalmatian if you look carefully at that
set of blobs inside that set of blobs
there's this outline you can kind of
tell there's a picture of a Dalmatian
but it's really hard to see because of
the background noise and the lack of
outline
it's it's not really clear what it is
until you see it but once you see it you
can kind of see that it's there okay so
that's one kind of problem the dalmatian
problem now we're going to do the other
problems Where's Waldo everybody if you
have kids or something you know about
the world of things they used to get
these illustrations as a picture with a
whole bunch of people and everybody's in
brightly colored outfits and the
question is Where's Waldo and the answer
is Walters right there I think a little
bit hard to tell but but these are
really different puzzles and the
question I want you to ask yourselves
how does the dalmatian puzzle differ
from the Waldo puzzle right in the
dalmatian case you had no idea what you
were looking for and it only became
obvious once your side right once
someone pointed out to you Oh see this
little cluster of black and white spots
if you look at it just right you'll see
the Dalmatian so in the Dalmatian case
yet no idea what you're looking for and
you pattern matched and pattern matched
until something fit and then that became
the Dalmatian but once you saw it it was
really quite simple don't see it again
but while the puzzle is quite different
you know exactly what you're looking for
you're looking for this guy that looks
like Waldo and then the only thing you
have to do is very carefully scan the
picture to match the image of Waldo so
this is this is exactly like finding
your future finding your place in the
world it's not a Waldo puzzle everybody
tries to turn it into all the puzzle
tell me what you're passionate about
tell me what you're good at
take this assessment and well you know
but and the assessment will say you
should be an architect or you should be
a you know doctor you should be a
garbage collector it doesn't work that
way
because it turns out in most cases
there's a lot more you that could
possibly be expressed than any of these
assessments could indicate and so we're
looking into the future in the future is
this set of really interesting but
ambiguous possibilities and we're and
we're trying to
see which one looks the most like me are
most like the Dalmatian but we need a
couple of different things for that to
work because we don't know exactly what
we're looking for it's not a Waldo in
the in the course of the class we've
developed a couple of different things
suggesting is that the designing of your
future is more like the Dalmatian puzzle
than the Waldo puzzle and so what we've
come up with is we've evolved a method
and kind of a model where we put design
thinking in the middle this accepts
define ID a prototype and test model and
below that we put some discovery and
support systems some practices for you
know making your life robust ways of
figuring decisions so we call
descendants ways of finding mentors and
putting the communities these things
that support your investigation using
design thinking about your life and then
above that we put them in making layer
we come up we write people write a point
of view a work view and a world view and
we combine those things with a series of
exercises we've got a bunch of different
exercises in the class on meaning-making
we do a world view Design Thinking
Odyssey year as a strengths class and
other things we do a whole bunch of
things inside the Design Thinking layer
and networking brainstorming reframes
operas vs. job major career linkages
things like that and then we do a bunch
of things in the discovery and support
layer all of which lead to something we
call an odyssey plan which is the final
piece that the students do in the class
but what I want to do today because we
can't obviously do all of this in an
hour I want to talk about two particular
assessments that we do that I think
really help with the you are here and
ground your investigation about your
potential futures in something that that
gives you a sort of a dashboard about
parts of your life particularly parts
that are relay
- how is the job career that you're in
fitting and with these assessments these
little dashboards kind of like think of
those like you know lights on your
dashboard on the car when they're nice
and green you know things are good when
they're yellow you know that maybe
something is going on and if you have a
red light on your dashboard you know
it's time to stop and pull over and take
a look at what's going on with the
vehicles same thing with your life and
these two assessments work in that
direction so the first idea is to
introduce you to the concept of flow
again we didn't invent this a
psychologist named Mihaly
Csikszentmihalyi I believe that is how
you spell it that's how you spell I
think that's how you say it he's one of
the early people in the positive
psychology movement he and Martin
Seligman were two of the founders of the
positive psychology movement positive
psychology is just the study of healthy
driving people to figure out what makes
them that versus the study of people
with psychosis and he wrote a book
called flow the optimum the psychology
of optimal experience and what he did is
he had people report in he had a method
of sort of interrupting people's daily
lives these are thousands and thousands
and thousands of people and they would
report in on their state and every once
in a while he noticed that people would
report hey I was doing this thing and it
was like wow I just time Stood Still and
I was totally engaged and he saw that
coming up again and again and again in
his data and he realized that this is
really what he had captured was this
sort of peak experience flow experience
people call it in the zone whatever but
it was an experience that was really
critical to people's sense of well-being
and driving so that's the but to cover
the book and the qualities of a flow
state are the time seems to stand still
you're completely involved in the
activity there's almost a sense of
ecstasy or pleasure about the thing
there's an inner clarity and serenity
now if you've ever if you do anything
athletic if you do anything you know
physical yoga or other things sometimes
you probably have experienced a state
like this everybody has these they're
not unique they're not special and what
he came up with this model and it's the
on the bottom exit
skills on the vertical axis challenge
and when the activity challenges you
just at the level of your ability and
that can be as a beginner or even as an
expert you're in what he called the flow
channel if the activity is doesn't
challenge your skills very much you're
in the boredom zone if the activity is
way beyond your your current skills
you're in the anxiety zone but when
you're right at that optimal point
imbalance you're in the flow channel and
you get so there's a challenge skill
balance you have really clear outcomes
that you're looking for you're getting
immediate feedback and you're hyper
focused in this state so this is a
really interesting state of being and
and it's not necessarily about some
extraordinary peak activity you don't
have to be climbing Everest to do this I
often find myself in flow states when
I'm cooking I enjoy cooking just
chopping an onion you know just being
right there chopping that onion and
getting it just right and making it
perfect a little 30-second flow state
sometimes when I'm reading researching
or I'm putting together you know a new
slide deck I'll have a flow state of
kind of really understanding exactly
what it doesn't want to say so you've
probably experienced these as well and
here's the homework that we have people
do and I'd like you if you're interested
I'd like you to take a look at this
I'd like you to keep what we call a flow
journal for one week and what you do is
it's just at the end of the day planning
to find yourself a little book a journal
or just a couple of pieces of paper
stapled together and I want you to
remember the day walking through the day
and saying I got up this morning and
with your Starbucks I came in the office
and the budget meeting whatever whatever
happened to you
put the write down any observations you
have of when you might have been either
in a very calm and relaxed state or all
the way into what you would consider a
flow State you can chest track you know
just tracking your experience and then
sort of isolating the ones that you
think might have been more flowy will in
fact cause you to remember the
and sort of savor it a bit and you will
probably start to notice if you do this
for a week that there are moments in
every day when you discover wow I was
totally engaged in that activity and
that wasn't even really you know I
wasn't distracted I wasn't multitasking
I wasn't I was right on balance okay so
the first piece of work that we have
students doing if you bite you to do if
you'd like is to keep afloat journal and
that leads to this to the next tool
which we look at this thing called
engagement versus energy so I'm going to
suggest that the next thing you do is
take the results of this flow journal
like I had a I had stayed the flow when
I was baking that cake and I had a state
of flow I was listening to you know
books on tape and I was just totally
engaged in the story whatever those are
take those entries from your flow
journal and add what we call engagements
from your weekend weekly calendar so
engagements or any discrete activities
that took us you know a significant
amount of your attention or energy not
not you know engagements I necessarily
pick up the kids from daycare but if you
carpool every week and you're part of
the carpool and that's one of your tasks
that you do every week that's an
engagement but just driving to the
grocery store isn't necessarily an
engagement so take the major engagements
from the week and put these on on a
timeline it's just sort of say I did
listen to this I did this I did the flow
state here flow state here they don't
have to necessarily be in the exact
order but I like to set a chart a week
and I want you to do it like this the
horizontal axis is my engagements you
see here I took a week of my engagements
I could meant the art class I did a
budget meeting of office hours with my
students I had a faculty meeting and so
on so this isn't my whole week but it's
a simplified set of you know kind of
major engagements for the week and then
I've got an energy axis the vertical
axis is energy above the axis is
positive energy below is negative now
this is a subjective judgment this is a
self-reported judgment does when I go to
art class do I leave with more energy
than I
or is the is it an energy sort of you
know depleting activity so my art class
is a three hours once a week I go to a
studio and we draw figured figure
drawing you know some we have a nude
model and we draw up for three hours no
matter how tired I am at the end of my
day because this hasn't happened until
seven o'clock in the evening on Mondays
how tired I am at the end of my day as
soon as I walk into that studio I'm
energized and I leave three hours later
paradoxically quite tired because it's
hard to draw for three hours and full of
energy
so it's subjective evaluation of you
know that that's an activity seems to
give me energy now we had a budgeting
meeting because we're doing some RIBA
jetting and Stanford here at and I
believe that meeting just exhausted it's
not an energy positive my office hours
with my students I love it I love
talking with my students super high
energy both of those I'd say I go into a
state of flow or oftentimes in office
hours I'll look up and I'm an hour late
for my next meeting but the engagement
with the students have been so
interesting that I just can't leave
faculty meeting sometimes good sometimes
bad straddles the line you get the idea
you know when I go for when I do a
workout and I do my two-mile walk and I
feel good about that I'm good so what I
want you to do is lay out this this this
time this sort of time engagements
versus energy graph based on activities
from your weekly calendar and and your
activities from your flow Journal just
do those two things and then you'll
probably notice some at you know some
interesting contradictions or some
interesting data one thing that I
noticed is that although I enjoy my
office hours I also have my master
students doing their thesis projects and
I do coaching every week we get together
for a coaching session I coached them on
their thesis projects and I noticed to
my surprise but when I actually sat down
and rated that that was an energy -
activity that was taking energy out of
my day now I like my master students and
if I see them in office hours it's quite
engaging but there's some was something
about masters coaching that wasn't
working for me so when I went in to
discover what that was all about it had
to do with the environment where
and ruinous messy studio environments so
I can't concentrate and it had to do
with the sort of negative engagement
that the coaching turned out it wasn't
coaching so much as telling them what
was good what was going wrong and so I
have taken action to change both of
those things I'm going to reread my
activities in a couple of weeks to see
if I've added energy to my day and you
know the it while it's suggested
subjective I want to I want to do a
little bit of things on this and
knowledge you guys ask questions after
this it's an interesting data that I've
been following them because I read a lot
of neuroscience on creativity it's kind
of my field so I need to know what's
going on and here's a really interesting
piece of data and it comes from a field
of neuroscience called neuro economics
where they're looking at energy
consumption the economy of the body is
it's basically just a big energy system
you take in about 2,000 calories a day
on average people here about 2,000
calories of food and that's the energy
your body runs on those 2,000 calories
now the interesting thing is that the
human brain only only weighs about 2 or
3 percent of your average body weight
it's about a three pound squishy ball of
neurons so you'd think well if it weighs
three percent of the body it should take
three percent of the energy but it turns
out the human brain is the most energy
consumptive organ in the body it takes
25% of the energy
500 calories a day just to run your
brain and the this theory posits that if
it took any more than that it would
there wouldn't be enough energy to run
your heart and liver and lungs and
everything else and so that the brain
has evolved to resource competition to
be as efficient as it can be but to take
as much energy as is possible
so what this tells me is that looking at
how you and what you attend to what you
literally pay attention to what your
reality is every day what you do what
you see what you think and how you spend
your attention is real iterally what
you're spending the majority of your
energy on this is what all that food is
being turned into it's being turned into
thought
actions and intentions so by paying
attention like plotting this as a graph
it's bringing us it's bringing this data
which is very subtle into our attention
and allowing us to act on it in a way
that we didn't have access to before so
it's a really interesting tool and we
find that when you do this it's a it's a
it's a huge opportunity to start to look
at what is working in your life that
satisfies you and what is working in
your life it's pulling energy out of you
and to redistribute that in a way that
works my examples was you know coaching
my master students I'm doing that now
and a completely new way I've prototyped
a new way to do it we're going to do
that for about two or three weeks and
I'm going to relook at this energy graph
and see what we get out of it I'd really
like to see the results of this
exercises from you guys and we have you
know hundreds of people and four hundred
and seventy four people on this webinar
right now and probably another couple
hundred will watch it you know not live
or listen to it not live so I'd love it
if people would actually take on the
challenge or doing a one-week flow
Journal and one and she's looking at a
one week of your daily tasks lay them
out in this energy versus engagement
graph and email it to me and for anybody
who does that we will send out a summary
of all the submissions back to the
people who've participated because I'm
I'm trying to get a larger data set on
this tool to see what sort of patterns
are revealed now just I'll just get the
first week normally we have people do
this assessment once a month I'll just
get the first week and maybe you can put
any comments down anomalies or things
that that have become clearer to you by
doing by using this tool so I'm
interested in that as well but I'm just
also interested to see what the summary
of you know energy distributions are as
does everybody think budget meetings are
boring does everybody love you know
coaching Little League teams I don't
know I mean I'm curious to see what will
happen
you can certainly and we will certainly
anonymize the data I'm not looking for
you to reveal anything you know private
or personal
and we will not I don't have any way to
save if you email it to me I'll know
it's your grandpa tab but I guarantee
you that we will not allow the
information to go back out tagged in any
way with identity I'm just curious to
see what um you know what people do when
they look at their lives through this
through this lens so the takeaways are
we actually do believe you can design
your life we have lots and lots of tools
gratefulness journal empathy maps we end
up with an odyssey plan three plans for
your future we really try to blow up the
myths that passion is the starting point
because it doesn't work for most people
we know that flow journals help us
notice when we're operating at our peak
and when we when we pay attention to
that notice when we notice these
behaviors we actually start changing the
behaviors and doing more of them we also
notice that when our energy goes goes
wherever our energy goes can be
redesigned and so that we can tune our
engagements to create a more effective
life and that our tension is what
consumes most of our energy and this is
not a zero-sum game you actually gain
energy above and beyond you know what
you have intrinsically by participating
in flow States peak experiences and and
and rebalancing your life to do the
things that are an energy positive not
sure you know the laws of thermodynamics
would say that's not true but I think
when we're thinking about the laws of
human dynamics there are more
possibilities so that's the that's the
deal I'm sure there are questions and
I'm happy to answer questions about you
know about you that the tool how to use
it or other things about designing your
life curriculum I've got a couple of
there's a couple of questions for a one
question is what's a kid with the Aki WI
Zi that is I know it when I see it
this pattern matching things that humans
are so good at I mean you know you you
have a massively
organized brain around this notion of
pattern matching with a lot of new brain
science on why the brain even exists but
one of the things that is in your brain
even before you know anything when you
come out of the womb you have the
ability immediately to recognize faces
infants immediately identify the faces
in the room when they're born note which
one is their mother and so the I know it
when I see it exercise is we show people
a whole series of things similar to the
dalmatian puzzle and they have you know
and they report their direct subjective
experience and oftentimes we find that
although it's hard to put certain things
into words
our ability to pattern match is so
extraordinary that we can find the
Dalmatians in our future just by being
open to this kind of observational thing
another question is the flow channel the
same as being in the zone sure it's
examing you know the zone the zone is
typically used to describe athletic
performance but sure it I believe
they're there
what checks emma has identified in the
psychology literature literature which
he named flow is really just validating
that there's own experience exists if
you've ever if you've ever been an
athlete at any level you know there are
certain times when you just can't miss
that jump shot or you just can't you
know that backhand that that backhand
down the you know reverse line in the
tennis match or something is just yours
and it you don't even have to think
about it or you hit the perfect you know
driver on the first hole of you know
your your golf game and the start of
your vacation and you just know it's
going to be a great game so yes flow and
flow and zone are probably identical
somebody's asking a question you know in
a world of interruptions email and short
attention spans and multitasking
do you have any suggestions for focusing
you know focusing and follow-through see
used to seem to be difficult because of
the way we are constantly bombarded with
interruptions I don't know about you
guys I get about 250 emails a day
probably a hundred of which are actually
actionable and so it is a very difficult
thing nowadays with the media
environments and the work environments
that we live in and people expect an
instant answer to most of their their
queries so it there is a discipline to
focus which is critical one of our
colleagues cliff Nass and the
communication school is the guy who did
the multitasking studies to demonstrate
that multitasking doesn't work that this
generation of students who think they're
so good at it are terrible and that in
fact the human brain isn't isn't set up
for multitasking but you're mostly doing
is doing sequential tasks very rapidly
over and over again you're breaking them
into smaller and smaller subsets the
subsidy do that you lose efficiency you
don't gain and so you know truly what
you spend your attention on is the only
thing you can think about a human
conscious thought process is a single
single channel and linear process so you
know they're not any number of
techniques for refining your focus and
turning off these other activities but I
think the important observation from
psychology that we use is that
multitasking is a myth and so you're you
think you're doing you think you are
gaining efficiency but you really not
and you want to not do it for flow
journals how likely is it that we're in
a flow state when we are doing something
that is different from routine and then
we lose that state if we if that that
new activity became routine I don't
think I don't think that's maybe the
right way to think about it in fact flow
states are often only come certainly
enough lad
six are in cooking or other skills based
activities flow states only come when
your skills reach a certain level and so
I think I think routine is part of
creating flow States and I don't think
you so I don't think you ruined the
ability to have flow if it becomes your
team but I think there are rote
activities which are mindless too that
would probably get in the way of flow
States both states are high attention
states if we put your brain in a brain
scanner many many parts of the brain are
lighting up and it is a very high
attention state to a singular activity
and so routine is actually helpful in
that regard I think we got to move to a
couple of other items just few things
quickly when's the book coming out in a
year from June and when is the
submissions do I think you know it's
going to take a week for people to kind
of complete the journal so it would I
give it two weeks from today is when
I'll probably gather up whatever the
submissions are and start doing this
sort of statistics on them and anything
that comes in after that I probably
won't use so let's say that if you can
get me something a couple weeks from
today that would be fantastic I got one
remember one last question with which I
think is in some ways sort of a summary
question and I'm not sure if the person
asking it was is is sort of happy sad or
mournful or
resigned the question is if you don't
know your passion then will you spend
your whole life looking for it or should
you just settle with what you've got and
be happy you know I think this is one of
the reasons why I just hate this passion
question it's like there's nothing wrong
with not having a passion so let me
reframe the question in a way that I
think might be more generative of course
I'm looking to design a future and my
job in my life you know with
with my friends my family my spouse my
relationships I wanted to be engaged I
wanted to be creative I wanted to be
exciting
all of those things are easily
understandable and you can navigate
towards good outcomes in all of those I
can look at my energy map and decide to
certain things just really suck energy
out of me and they're not going to want
them to be part in my job description
anymore and I can work over the next 6
or 12 months to sort of maximize the
number of things I do in the job that
that utilized my signature strengths
that helped me be more creative and that
add you know add to my connections with
my colleagues and my peers so I can do
those things and I can I can do other
things to manage the things that I do in
my life to move towards creativity
towards engagement towards the kinds of
things that the positive psychologists
have shown us create you know a more of
a thriving lifestyle I need to be
engaged I need achievement I need I need
to be recognized for the work that I do
so once I once that I'm aware of these
things I can start designing and
prototyping small changes in my life to
get the kinds of things more and more
often no one has a perfect life no one
has a life that not this there's you
know it's not all you know a hot fudge
sundaes and and stuff sometimes there's
broccoli sometimes there's Brussels
sprouts or whatever vegetable you don't
like I happen to kind of like Brussels
sprouts now they've gone to a resurgence
in my diet but I mean there's always
going to be stuff it's tough it's not
about that it's about resiliency it's
about having a sense of direction which
gives you a sense of purpose Daniel pink
in his book on on on motivation called
Drive said that you know people work for
autonomy mastery and purpose autonomy
you give yourself mastery you create by
working hard and developing skills and
purpose is what comes from a intentional
design of your life and so I don't think
you're ever going to never
say I'm going to settle for what I have
and be happy with it but Martin Seligman
one of the other founders of the
positive psychology movement says look
it's not about finding the perfect job
that's just not out there it's about
finding the job you can make perfect and
there's a whole thing we do in class
around discernments how do we know what
we know how do we how do we know what
our gut feelings are really telling us
how can we take our intuitive
understandings and matching them up with
our explicit rational understanding and
come up with a way to discern what's the
right path for me forward it's it's it's
hard work but it's but it's but all that
information is available to you and so
we're really committed to what can you
do what's the next step what's the next
step after that because if you if you
work on the job you can make perfect and
you employ this sort of attention to
these these kinds of outcomes our
experiences you get what you plan for
you get what your design and then when
you put yourself in the next situation
you've designed a new set of
configurations of the world and your
relationships then new things become
available to you and in that process
sort of virtuous cycle of designing your
way forward designing your way forward
you find yourself after a while really
starting to notice all of the ways in
which your life design is coming
together to make you a more generous
more generative more creative person we
all have a very creative person inside
us David Kelly's new book on creative
confidence David his brother Tom wrote
this some about creative confidence
everybody has a creative person inside
them I don't care what you what what
script you are currently repeating in
your head about yourself as a creative
person you were creative when you were
three or four or five somewhere along
the line through education or some other
socialization process maybe you lost
confidence in that creativity but once
you turn that back on by using design
technology design methods to turn it
back on you can apply that creativity to
the most important and most interesting
design problem you've got
that's your life so we have some we have
some evidence we've had two PhD study
the technique we've shown statistically
significant increases in self
actualization and creativity and getting
rid of dysfunctional beliefs beliefs
that are not functional but about your
life and what it means and so we we
actually have what we would consider to
be scientific or at least social
scientists validation of the methodology
so we're out of time I'm going to leave
it to leave you with there thank you
very much for your attention and
hopefully you weren't multitasking and
we have a second half of this will be on
a shirt so please join us for the next
event on May 13th prototypes for
personal success and if you're
interested in additional webinars prior
to that event we also have webinars
available on the SCP website SCPD
stanford.edu thanks for joining us
bye-bye